endlich sommer urlaub endlich geht das
denkst du jetzt kommt schon wieder der
nächste urlaub summer stell dir vor du
hast urlaub in portugal gebucht freut
sich darauf nach dieser ganzen urlaubs
geschichte des letzten jahres und jetzt
wird auch dieser urlaub wieder
kaputtgemacht portugal zum
virusvarianten gebiet erklärt heute seit
mitternacht ja man muss jetzt also
wieder in quarantäne
das macht so muss man sagen eigentlich
den kompletten urlaub für die
allermeisten von uns komplett kaputt
ganz genau lass uns noch mal schauen was
das bedeutet virusvarianten gebiet
einmal hier auf die tafel geguckt was
sind im moment virusvarianten gebiete in
deutsch in europa wir haben die einmal
gelb eingefärbt zum glück gibt es noch
nicht so ganz viele russland da wollen
die am meisten von uns nicht hin im
urlaub hier großbritannien da wollen
heute ganz viele deutsche hin nämlich
zum fußballspielen nach wembley geht
halt auch nicht danach quarantäne und
hier unten jetzt ganz frisch seit heute
nacht portugal seit 0 uhr portugal die
algarve liste lissabon ein ganz
beliebtes reiseziel für zehntausende von
uns zehntausende deutsche urlauber was
bedeutet das jetzt macht die regierung
macht die politik uns jetzt auch noch
den sommerurlaub kaputt darüber müssen
wir sprechen wir natürlich hören wie
bitter ist das dann eigentlich wir haben
uns an flughäfen um gehört denn jetzt
versuchen alle aus portugal wieder
rauszukommen um dieser quarantäne
entgegenzuwirken und das ist stressig
und vor allem überhaupt nicht günstig
die leute waren richtig in panik manche
rannten da durch die gegend weil sie nur
noch für 15 minuten hatten weil die
schlange für die tests halt auch so
lange waren und gestern war sonntag
hätte man sich ja kein test machen
können von daher waren die schon viele
waren schon da in panik und hatten angst
dass sie ihren flug nicht bekommen
schrecklich was das war nicht schön
der flieger war komplett ausgebucht die
haben sogar die koffer zwischen die
beine gehabt habe überhaupt keinen platz
mehr hatten
in diesen gepäckträger was man hat um
die 500 euro noch mal aufpassen
bis zum wochen annähernd 500
hunderte euro drauf für diese portugal
urlauber die koffer zwischen die beine
und zack so schnell wie möglich raus aus
dem land damit man nicht unter diese
quarantäne regelung kurzfristig
beschlossen fällt darüber müssen wir
sprechen mit dem spd gesundheitsexperten
karl lauterbach guten tag herr
lauterbach
warum passiert das wieder warum machen
sie das wieder so schnell so hastig
urlaub kaputt für die die sich so sehr
auf ihren sommerurlaub gefreut haben
ich sag mal so sagen eine ganz kleine
gruppe nur diejenigen die jetzt portugal
urlaub gemacht haben die handels
betroffen und alternative wäre dass wir
tatsächlich also hier
wenn wir nicht handeln flächendeckend
die data warnt ins land lassen
dann würden sie in wenigen wochen
sendungen nachher mit dem thema ja wie
konnte das passieren dass wir so viele
ausbrüche in den schulen zum beispiel
haben wir haben einfach nur die
möglichkeit vorsichtig zu sein und die
bürger zu schützen
und da müssen die urlauber die pech
haben und jetzt nahm solchen also gebiet
leider urlaub gemacht haben also dass
ich in die quarantäne müssen das ist ja
das unangenehm und der schnellen abdruck
machen oder aber wir lassen das laufen
aber wir können es nicht laufen lassen
dafür ist es einfach zu gefährlich und
wir kämpfen hier gemeinsam im
politischen berlin nach rum dass wir
eine große virtuelle im herbst nicht
noch mal rollen wir wollen nicht aber
sie aber sie widersprechen sich austria
ist auch selbst auf der einen seite
sagen sie menschen sind nur so ein paar
urlauber und auf der anderen seite
erklären sie die zum nationalen risiko
man hätte doch wenigstens die urlauber
die jetzt schon da sind in ruhe ihren
urlaub zu ende machen können stattdessen
müssen die jetzt über alter abreisen
tragen auch noch die höheren kosten und
müssen tag nach wenigen tagen nach
deutschland vor dieser 00 uhr frist
heute nacht
so ist es ja nicht sind ja schnell
abgegrast um die 14 tage quarantäne zu
umgehen
die hätten ja da bleiben können wie
einige auch da geblieben sind und hätten
dann den contender muss aber das gilt
für jeden wenn man in den urlaub fährt
und wer hat man im urlaub ist wird das
urlaubsland zum bio austria dann kommt
man entweder ganz schnell zurück oder
man musste man zurückkommt in cannes
so sind die regeln ja so sind die regeln
die frage ist ob es sinnvoll ist wenn
sie einerseits sagen das sind so ein
paar urlauber und auf der anderen seite
machen sie denen das leben so schwer und
sagen ja
da müsst ihr halt danach 14 tage in
quarantäne das macht ja kein mensch der
nach arbeiten gehen muss der muss ja
zurückgefahren zurückfliegen die hat er
gar keine andere wahl
es ist nicht anders zu regeln
jetzt ist es so dass wir noch die
möglichkeit haben wir haben jetzt auch
die möglichkeit eine große delle durch
reiserückkehrer zu verhindern und das
wollen
ich habe den ansatz noch ich hab die
menge dass es nicht so viele sind
bezogen noch die große zahl derjenigen
die den urlaub fahren jetzt insgesamt
das sagt machen sehr viele im urlaub in
deutschland das machen jetzt sehr vielen
urlaubsländern anti virus varianten
na ja dann nein darf nicht der eindruck
entstehen als wenn wir jetzt den
urlaubern ganz grundsätzlich den urlaub
verderben sondern sind stark leider es
ist sagen wir zum glück aber dank für
die betroffenen sehr leid
es ist diese kleine gruppe derer die
sich ausgerechnet herr lauterbach aber
dieses jahr im sommer gibt es ja
eigentlich eine positive nachricht viele
der urlauber einige der urlauber sind
komplett durchgeimpft warum müssen die
auch zurück warum können die nicht
ausgeschlossen werden von diesen
quarantäne regeln sie sind komplett
durch gf sollten also jetzt kein risiko
für irgendjemanden sein wenn sie
zurückkommen weil wir wussten ja ist es
so dass wir am anfang nicht genau wissen
wie gut die eben vom tatsächlich wirkt
wir haben bisher hinweise darauf dass
tatsächlich die also zumindest die
bayern tag doch bei dem pfund auch
matschie nicht im modernen café irgendwo
hier sehr gut wirkt und somit eine
erkrankung verhindert wissen ist aber
noch nicht ganz genau
und tatsächlich ist das etwas was man
mittelfristig auch anpassen könnte dass
man für die doppel geben wenn sich
herausstellt dass die täter irgendwo bei
den doppelten ich wirklich durchbricht
dass man bei den doppelten dank an den
deutschen nur dass ich denn das sonst
den faden verlieren
das ist also etwas was ich auch medizin
nicht für sinnvoll hielte das jetzt zu
prüfen das könnte in den nächsten wochen
geschlossen werden also was genau
bedeutet dann in ihren augen
mittelfristig wenn ich doppelt geimpft
bin wie viel angst muss ich jetzt noch
haben das vielleicht mein urlaub will er
demnächst auch diese virusvarianten
gebiete werden und ich gar nicht fahren
kann aber wenn der urlaub vorbei in den
nächsten wochen sagte lauterbach in die
ferien vorbei sind
nein das sage ich nicht es muss eben
medizin nicht also geprüft werden und da
kann man es eben nicht beschleunigen
ich halte es für möglich dass wir in
wenigen wochen
das ist meine persönliche meinung in
sicht auf die daten dass wir in wenigen
wochen sagen dass diejenigen die als
virusvarianten gebieten kommen und die
doppelten sind und wenn die virus
varianten solche sind wo wir wissen dass
dienstag verwirrten dass wir dann
diejenigen die doch die inseln und er
kann endlich befreit das wäre mal eine
persönliche verwicklung
im vergangenen jahr waren das ja gar
nicht die urlauber die touristen die
korona dann im sommer hierher gebracht
haben das waren schwerpunktmäßig
familien heimkehrer vom balkan die ganz
ganz viel corona erkrankungen sozusagen
mitgebracht haben warum dann diese
harten regelung die sind nicht
gerechtfertigt er lauterbach da ist ja
das war seine antwort eigentlich wieder
90 können sie mich wieder sehen ja wohl
okay sekunde
ich habe irgendwann bild problem so ein
problem
wir warten den moment die frage ist nach
der tatsächlichen gefährlichkeit von
urlaubern die ist bisher nicht
nachgewiesen im letzten sommer waren das
nicht deutsche touristen die massenweise
das virus nach hause gebracht haben von
mallorca oder aus portugal und so weiter
naja es waren auch berichten und wir
haben wie viele 14 50 60 das kann ich
jetzt also
aus dem kopf heraus ich bin ja sagen
vermutlich deutlich weniger deutlich
weniger an sich hier angestellt haben
wenn ich trotzdem den satz sagen
nachweisverfahren hat ihr erstes also
haben wir mit dem schutz damals auch
viel erreicht also wir haben bei der
einreise art betrügt und wir haben die
urlauber angehalten sich sehr vorsichtig
zu fahren und somit dass es die tatsache
dass es nicht so viele gewesen sind und
damit haben sie recht aber das ist auch
ein erfolg der maßnahmen gewesen
und diesmal haben wir darüber hinaus
eine gefährliche variante die wir in
deutschland hat nicht flächendeckend
haben fordert wollen wir auch deshalb
nicht weil wir unsere kinder schützen
wollen damit sie haben recht das war im
letzten jahr nicht so viel aber es macht
auch an ergebnis der maßnahmen die wir
ergriffen haben
trotzdem stimme ich ihnen zu windows
varianten gebiete hier also mit antenne
tatsächlich kämpfen müssen dann sollte
man also wahrscheinlich sollte man
ausschließen
herr lauterbach wenn wir über die data
variante sprechen müssen wir natürlich
auch mal wieder über kinder sprechen sie
haben getwittert dass diese ganz
besonders krank